episode sees many twists and surprises
euron's death as well as a huge
revelation behind the night king's
motivation and his reasons of marching
south
most of the events are seemingly
confirmed by leaked photos just like
most of the events in the previous
episodes
if you're new here and are wondering why
this particular outline might be the
actual outline of the final season of
game of thrones let me explain to you
real quick
all the previous episodes including the
following ones have major events that
have been confirmed by many leaked
photos but the kicker is that this same
outline was sent to me in the august
last year
while filming for the final season began
in october last year long story short
this outline was sent to me before the
filming for the final season began and
yet all the leaked photos from the
filming set that followed seemed to be
perfectly matching with this outline if
you haven't seen the previous three
outlines for the first three episodes of
season 8 i highly suggest you to do so
and then come back
to watch this video anyways it says that
the episode starts with an aftermath of
a battle for winterfell
winterfell is in ruins we see many dead
bodies inside and
outside winterfell i gotta stop right
there to point out that this opening
scene of episode 4 might have been
confirmed by a bunch of leaked photos
from winterfell set the previous episode
saw a huge battle fought in winterfell
between the living and the dead and
later a battle among the living
it only makes sense for us to see the
aftermath of those massive battles
and we built we will see a few shots of
the corpses through across the snow
covered fields just outside winterfell
back to the outline it states that the
next scene is in king's landing john is
being escorted through the city walls to
cersei
john and cersei have a meeting on the
city walls john is not in chains
john and cersei are accompanied by
cersei's queensguard including the
mountain and qyburn
this part has been confirmed by many
league photos as well jenny's being
escorted through the city of also cersei
it says and this leaked photo supports
it
john and cersei have a meeting on the
city walls john is not in chains john
and cersei are accompanied by cersei's
queensguard including the mountain and
qyburn it says
and these leaked photos seem to be
confirming it anyways the outline
continues with you know when your father
came here and fought out my little
secret he gave me a choice
suffer the consequences or flee and save
your children honorable man
honorable fool says cersei to john i
surrendered to avoid losing more men in
pointless battles
you still have a child to live for you
don't need to do this replies jon what
child would that be
three that were taken from me or the one
that i lost in miscarriage i will fight
and take what is mine by right says
cersei your firstborn son the
black-haired boy his name is ginger
replies shaun
cersei is stunned she didn't know anyone
knew about is beside her and jaime
cersei orders john to be taken into the
dungeons until she figures out the most
painful death upon him cersei grows more
and more mad
and paranoid before he could be taken
john says to cersei you can't kill me
cersei poses so orders her mantle stop
for a moment
and why not she asks john because the
nearest will burn you and your keep down
answer john why do you think i captured
you respond cersei by looking at
qyburn's new and many scorpions
john realizes what's going on and shucks
says it's a chat for the nearest center
dragons
30 smiles i've already talked quite a
lot about genji being cersei's son in
the episode 3 outline video where it's
been revealed to him by jaime
additionally i made a full video
providing all the hints and clues
proving that genji could be the first
born black hair beauty son of king
robert and queen cersei so i will not
talk about it anymore however qyburn's
new scorpions made to kill dany's
remaining dragon's part has been
confirmed by the leaked video here's one
of qyburn's new scorpions on season 8
filming set much bigger than the
previous one that wounded dragon and has
two additional arms presumably to
increase tension
there will be three new scorpions to fix
dunking's landing walls
the outline then states that the next
shot is somewhere in the north sansaria
ghost
davos tyrion miss sandy grey warm
brienne ali skarstar cleona mormont lord
mannerly lord glower
jorah center clegane gilly sam little
sam robin and rayne branstar kemirtali
braun and jamie are heading south with
the unsullied the tally frey lannister
army and the small remaining number of
the north nurse and even smaller number
of the dotraki didn't think you'd be
alive
jaime says to arya arya poses thank you
for saying my brother and my sister but
i can't forgive you for what you and
your family have done to mine you're as
much guilty for my father's death as
joffrey she replies
brienne doesn't like this bren
interrupts and says not at all just the
opposite he said our father wants from
certain death from the mad king and
wildfire instead of a king's lair people
should call him their hero he also said
brienne to find and take care of you and
sansa he fulfilled his promise to her
mother bran continues
jaime is shocked to hear this from a boy
he once attempted to murder brienne is
happy for jaime arya doesn't reply to
this
varys is not here he's departed from the
group shortly after euron the golden
company captured just snow okay after
they lost most armies fighting the night
king's army and after they lost jean to
euron and the golden company the living
are now marching south
their armies are now mostly consisted of
the unsullied then the tally frey
lannister army with a small amount of
the surviving northerners and even
smaller amounts of
the jackie the ones who flee diazone we
are having a small talk between
arya and jaime i'm happy to see bran
defending jaime in this conversation the
part in which bran says that jaime saved
their father's life once most likely
refers on jimmy killing the mad king
had jaime not killed the met king the
entire capital would have been burned
down with all its population
including that stark who was somewhere
inside it at the moment anyways the
outline continues with the next shot is
summer south in dorne then airson dragon
accompanied with rhaegal attacks the
night king
and his undead dragon on that wizarding
wounds regal badly
regal flees drogon wounds viserion
pretty badly biting off big piece of
viserion's body but it seems as if it
does no damage to viserion
daenerys then starts burning the night
king's new army with drogon but is
forced to flee as the night king
attempts to kill jogon with a nice spear
the dance of the dragons finally a
dragon battles a dragon
then he left winterfell with her two
dragons in order to stop the night king
from resurrecting the dead across the
westeros and from killing everyone in
the south however dany has seemingly
came a bit too late
the night king already formed a new
bigger arm in the south drogon and
rhaegal battle visery under regal is the
first one to be almost killed whereupon
he flees
it says that dragon wounds viserion
pretty badly but it does not affect him
this is because viserion is not a living
dragon he is a reanimated corpse raised
by the night king
the dead are indestructible and can
instead an injury that would normally be
fatal
danny then tries to at least burn down
some of the new night king's army of the
dead but is forced to flee once the
night king starts throwing a nice spear
on dragon
let's hope regal survived this battle
back to the outline it says that we
learned that mel sanjaya has been in the
north this entire season in the form of
an old woman
genji and jaime have a conversation
genji asks jaime if he's sure in his
claims of him
being cersei's first born son with king
robert jimmy assures gain during this
jaime reveals to genji how he personally
paid tab among the apprentice fee as
well as to keep his mouth shut let me
stop right there to say that mel sanjaya
being in the north in the form of an old
woman has been quite expected with her
being banished from the north and warned
to be killed if ever comes back it only
makes sense for her to take over
necklace along with her illusion of
beauty and once again reveal her true
form and that way avoid being recognized
jimmy reveals to gendry that he
personally made sure that he was left in
good hands by paying the best blacksmith
in all of westeros to take care of him
and learn him forge high-end weapons and
armor
it's actually known that the unknown
lord paid genji's apprentice feast so he
could learn to be a blacksmith and as
it turns out it was nonetheless than
jaime himself genji's uncle
back to the outline daenerys rides drogo
north to winterfell she sees her
sanjan's forces marching south in the
riverlands
she lands tyrion and sansa tell her what
happened in winterfell they tell her
that cersei has jon snow now
jaime explains how cersei betrayed them
and how euron brought the golden company
to westeros
daenerys tells them that she failed to
stop the night king from forming a new
army in the south
she came too late davos notice says that
there is only one dragon rhaegal is not
there
the nair says that she doesn't know
where a girl is or if he's even alive
sometime later tyrion tells the nearest
about joshua lineage daenerys reveals
during her pregnancy with john's baby
seems like danny is the last one to
learn the truth about john's true
lineage it's been revealed to john back
in episode 2 almost everyone learns it
in the previous episode van bren
revealed it on a huge meeting after just
been taken captive and now then he
finally learns it as well
then it's pregnant stevie john's baby on
the other hand is still a secret of
tyrion being the only one beside mr
walken and is send it to know
then his pregnancy might not have been
confirmed by leaked photos but it
certainly has been heavily hinted and
foreshadowed throughout the previous
season
the outline continues with theo and they
are joined the nearest to the armborne
the nearest is happy to see are alive
it's revealed that you're on tortured
yara and cut out her tongue the next
scene takes place in the red keep
euron wants cersei to fulfill her
promise he wants a wedding
iron says that he fulfilled his part of
destroying her enemies it's time for her
to fulfill her part
cersei refuses thanks tiron for all the
support he provided and breaks their
allegiance
search reveals to euron that the golden
company has broken a contract no longer
fighting for her nor him
cersei states that as of now her only
allies wildfire
cersei has yearn killed by the mountain
whoa what a twist
the golden company apparently has broken
a contract and to be honest i've
expected it
with them never breaking a contract
being mentioned so many times and it
searches statement that no one walks
away from her this turn of events has
been both hinted and foreshadowed it's
been mentioned in a season premiere that
cersei has gone fully mad after she's
lost her only remaining child and hope
for the future of her house in a
miscarriage and we get to see it in its
full might this episode
cersei kills her only remaining ally and
proclaims wildfire her only ally in the
wars to come the scene switches to the
nearest camp
she thanks ferris for her service how
did you convince the golden company to
take up the cause of our queen when they
have spent so much of their history
fighting against the targaryens
tyrion asks varys their censors with not
only for our queen but for our king too
for aegon targaryen
black or red the dragon is still a
dragon at first it looked like the
golden company might have fled westeros
upon breaking a contract with cersei but
no varus who's been missing after jon's
resurrection has seemingly made a deal
with the gone and company
he says the golden company will fight
not only for daenerys but for aegon
targaryen as well
it means that varys revealed them that
jon snow is actually a targaryen whose
real name is aegon let me point out that
in the books the golden company also
breaks a contract for the very first
time to support a character by the name
jan griff whom they claim is prince sake
on targaryen see this little connection
between the books and the show
back to the outline it says that cersei
visits jon with qyburn and the mountain
in the dungeons
you were right she says to john we
should stand against the night king
together and they will cersei continues
john and qyburn are surprised by this
turn of events i have the scorpions i
have wildfire you and the nearest have
armies and the dragons cersei says
i'm happy to hear that willis semi-free
asks jon no you will send a raven to
your queen
answer cersei and continues with what do
you take me for a fool
asks cersei and continues with you're
the only reason the mad king's daughter
won't attack me with their dragons i
will allow all of them to come and stand
the final ground inside a capital but i
will keep you here with me you're my
only assurance they won't sack the city
once the gates open
and try to overthrow me johnson asks
where are they
for what i've heard the nearest and
their armies are somewhere in the
riverlands that's where the golden
company is heading too
john pauses not to attack but to pledge
loyalty to the dragon queen
king's landing has over a million people
in it it cannot fall it must not fall
write your people to come here and help
me defend it the gates will be open
cerses says john nuts the night king's
motivation is revealed the scene ties
together every white walker symbol we've
seen throughout the series
there are not mindless zombies marching
south to kill everyone let me stop right
there to say that even though this rough
outline doesn't provide much details
about this huge revelation regarding
night king and his motivations
it still makes me happy to know that
they'll finally find out what does he
want
it says that the revelation scene ties
together every white walker symbol we've
seen throughout the series scene which
will probably leave us speechless but
nonetheless this major event might have
also been kind of confirmed by season 8
filming leaks the production returned to
polymorph forest and filmed a few scenes
for the final season
for anyone that doesn't know polymor
forest was famously used for the area
where the night swatch rangers
encountered white walkers and their
symbol in the very first sequence of the
show will these new film scenes be used
to finally explain the ominous symbol as
the outline states and finally shed
light on the night king's history
motivation and goal
one can only hope if this outline comes
true i'd say that these huge revelations
will be seen through bran stark's
visions
back to the outline the episode ends
with the scenes of the entire living
side led by daenerys and jaime
approaching king's landing while
cersei's voiceover explains the plans to
qyburn will we open the city gates when
they arrive ask skyburn
yes we will search replies we will add
them all inside we will let them prepare
the city defenses we will work with them
when the time comes when all our enemies
start fighting in the streets of the
capital we will burn them all with
wildfire we see the night king marching
towards king's landing with his army too
even this major part of the outline has
been confirmed by the leaked photos and
videos from king's landing set
here you can see the unsullied and
what's left of the detractor marching
towards king's landing gates just like
the outline states
cersei basically intends to use wildfire
and burn the entire king's landing to
the ground once the living and the dead
start fighting inside her city and that
way get rid of all her enemies
there you have it guys seemingly legit
outlined for episode 4 of the final
season
many of you were extremely happy with
the previous episode that was intense
and action packed and even though this
episode did see many twists and
surprises the following episode 5 takes
it to hall another level with a huge
battle for king's landing